well cars certainly have history they
have a lot of personality
and mecum auto auctions is giving you
the opportunity to maybe buy the car of
your dreams
jc fernandez is at the convention center
with the details for us
this has got to be car heaven 600 cars
motorcycles will be auctioned off this
weekend at mecum auto auctions
this car right behind me is one of them
and this car is a very special vehicle
it's a chevelle ss and here's the reason
why it is so special
it is owned by mark andre fleury even
mark andre fleury will be auctioning off
some vehicles at mecum auto auctions
this weekend
what's even really cool about this is
that counts customs here in las vegas
they built this car so it's accounts
custom build now mecum auto auctions
they come here to las vegas all the time
and normally they have thousands of
people here they have
all kinds of bidders here but because of
social distancing and the pandemic it is
closed to the public
you can watch the auction online now
stacy is one of the guys selling
a couple of cars here this weekend right
stacey i am so what is this truck you
have here
it's a 1945 chevy it's kind of rare
because there's not many 45s because
that was the wartime era so
it's a gorgeous truck and you also have
lance pan around uh you've got a royal
voice for sale
how much are you looking to get for that
rolls this weekend um
the low estimate is 150 000
north 150 000 north that's how mecum
auctions works actually the most
expensive car ever sold
at mecum auto auctions was 3.7 million
dollars
thank you stacy 3.7 million dollars that
sold back
in january again you can watch all of
this online this weekend
you can bid online let's check out these
mustangs
the boss 302 this is an insane mustang
this is a 2013 this car right here has
440
horsepower and here's something else too
about the
mecum auto auctions which is kind of
cool everything looks really
everything looks spread out because they
actually have social distancing
between the cars they got everything
covered now lance get a shot of this one
steve mcqueen fans would recognize this
ford mustang gt500 fastback
i think it's a 1967. let me see
1967. this is a beautiful piece of
machinery
that if you have that kind of money to
buy a really cool muscle car
you can jump online and do it one more i
got to show you one more i'm car having
over here look at this
look at this car right here 1969
chevy camaro it's a six-speed beautiful
piece of machinery camaro ss
gorgeous gorgeous car all kinds of
trucks out here motorcycles too
they're actually going to have
automobile art for sale it's the mecum
auto auctions it's happening online this
weekend at the las vegas convention
center
you guys can uh bid on your favorite
muscle car we'll send it back to you
in the studio i'm in heaven look at this
one over here
all right